Let's talk some more about binocular disparity.
As I mentioned before it’s a technique that's
very widespread through animals and it's also
a techniques that's used in robotics.
A good way to try and understand the principle
of binocular disparity is to look at this
very old-fashioned stereo photograph. It's
a pair of photographs of the same scene but
each image is being taken from a slightly
different viewpoint and this corresponds to
the viewpoint from our left eye and our right
eye.
This is separated by that 8 to 10 centimetres
and they give you a very slightly different
view of the world. Initial inspection of this
stereo photograph indicates that there's not
much difference. If we zoom in on a couple
of there is here, we see that in the left
hand image, there's quite a gap and there's
in fact no gap in the right hand image.
If we look on the other side of the picture,
we look at this bench. It's quite close to
the edge of the image in the left picture
and there is a bit of a gap between the edge
and the bench in the right hand image. It's
this very subtle differences in the image
taken from these 2 viewpoints that gives us
this very vivid 3-dimensional perception of
the world that's around us.
The fundamental principle of stereo disparity
is that the image depends on the camera position
and we can demonstrate that pretty easily.
If I move my head, if I translate my head
from the right through to the left then, everything
that's in the world appears to move to the
right but importantly, things that are close
to me like this robot here, appear to move
a lot in the image as I do that shift. Whereas
things that are far away like the bookcase,
appear to move much less.
The people have been interested in capturing
stereo photographs for a very very long time.
This is a lovely picture I found of a commercial
stereo film camera from the 1950's. A more
modern version of a stereo camera, this is
a digital stereo camera of this type that's
quite widely used for robotic systems.
Let's now try and understand what precisely
are the differences between the left hand
image and the right hand image of the same
scene. This is a pair of high-resolution digital
images of a pile of rocks.
I'm going to draw a line from the left hand
edge of the image to a fairly distinctive
blotch on one of the rocks and I'm going to
draw the same length line in the right hand
image. The yellow line has gone too far to
the right and in fact, we need to go back
the distance in order to get to this distinctive
mark on the rock.
Let's pick another distinctive feature at
the back of the scene here. So, I'm going
to draw a yellow line from the left hand edge
to the edge of one of the large blocks at
the back. I draw the same line in the right
hand image and again, we see that it's overshot,
the corresponding point and I need to go back the distance in order to get to that corresponding point.
We noticed 2 important things. First of all,
we noticed that points in the right hand image
are shifted somewhat to the left and this
shift, this horizontal displacement is referred
to as disparity. We also note that the shift is less for points that are further away from the camera.
So, here we have a stereo camera and it's
observing an object, a ball and that is at
distance Z away from the camera. We refer
to the base line of the stereo camera, that's
the distance between the centre of the lenses
and F is the focal length of the lens. We
assume that both lenses have the same focal
length.
Now, this is a very simple relationship between
these quantities and that is that the disparity
is proportional to the focal length and base
line divided by the distance. So, if we know
the focal length. We know the base line and
we know the disparity in the image then, we
could estimate Z. This is the fundamental
underlying principle of robotic stereovision,
sometimes it's called computational stereo and implicitly, it's what happens in our own visual system.